hey everyone this is shootie from simply
learned this video is going to be a
tutorial on CSS p we have an interesting
lineup for this video we will understand
why CSS p certification is important
what exactly cissp is we will also look
into the CSS P exam and its requirements
and finally we will have a look at the
way they CSS P domains so let's start
off this tutorial by understanding the
need for the CISSP certification if you
have seen our previous videos you would
be aware of the various cybersecurity
certifications like CCNA come to your
security plus C is M C is C and CH to
name a few you might have also come
across the CSS P certification let me
tell you this is one of the toughest and
most in-demand certification in the
cyber security field in the current
times managing information security in a
company can be extremely challenging
with the advent of the internet and
various other technologies there is a
large exposure to various security
breaches the presence of information
security experts in-house helps
organizations manage their IT processes
in a better way this is where a CSP
professional is in demand by employers
compared to the other cyber security
professionals the demand for CSS be
certified professionals has grown
rapidly there are nearly 50 thousand job
postings for the same now that you have
an idea of the demand of CSP certified
professionals let's move on to
understanding what exactly cissp CSP
stands for certified information systems
security professional it is considered
the gold standard in the field of
information security this certification
is taken up by IT professionals it
trains a candidate to become an
information assurance professional
taking up the CSP certification will
help you define the design architecture
controls and management of highly secure
business environments you will also be
called the CSS be professional only
after you successfully pass the CSP exam
so now let's have a look into the CSP
exam requirements the primary
requirement for any candidate is that
they should have at least five years of
work experience in the field of
information security in addition to this
it is also suggested that the candidate
clears our
certifications like CCNA CompTIA
security plus CH CS m and C is a to name
a few
CS SP is considered as an advanced level
cybersecurity certification hence it is
better if the candidate clears the basic
level and the managerial level
certifications before moving to the CSP
certification as I mentioned earlier
this certification is suitable for
professionals who have a minimum of five
years of work experience professionals
working as security consultants and
managers Network and security architects
IT directors security auditors and chief
information security officers can take
up the CSP certification now let's move
on and understand more about the CISSP
exam this certification is developed by
the international information system
security certification consortium is
e-square the certificate provider is IC
square you have to pay an exam fee of
699 dollars to take up this exam as I
mentioned earlier this is one of the
toughest exams and it is quite a long
one with a duration of six SARS
you would have to answer 250 questions
in six hours the exam consists of
multiple choice questions you need to be
able to get a minimum score of 700 out
of thousand for passing the CSP exam
let's now move on to our next topic that
is cissp domains this entire
certification is grouped into a total of
eight domains the broad spectrum of
topics included in CS SP ensure its
relevance across all disciplines in the
fields of information security
successful candidates are competent in
the following eight domains they are
security and risk management then we
have asset security security engineering
communications and network security
followed by identity and access
management then security assessment and
testing security operations and finally
we have software development security
these eight domains deal with different
aspects of information security we will
have a look into each of these
individually and understand what each of
these domains symbolize first up we have
the security and risk management domain
as the name suggests this domain mainly
consists of the fundamentals of security
policies compliance law and regulations
professional ethics risk management and
threat modeling cyber security and
security plays a major role in this
domain there is a difference between
cybersecurity and information security
which is more often missed out on by
people cybersecurity refers to several
techniques used to protect the integrity
of networks whereas information security
refers to processes and tools deployed
to protect sensitive information to
implement cyber security we have a list
of approaches like compliance based ad
hoc and risk based in compliance based
security measures are decided based on
regulations while in ad hoc security
measures are based on no specific
criteria in risk-based security measures
are based on unique risks depending on
the organization let's now have a look
at the CIA triad here C stands for
confidentiality I for integrity and a
for availability confidentiality
integrity and availability have served
as the industry standard for computer
security since the time of the first
mainframes confidentiality means that
information and functions can be
accessed only by authorized parties for
example military secrets integrity means
that information and functions can be
added altered or removed only by
authorized people and availability means
that systems functions and data must be
available on demand now that we have
understood the CIA triad let's have a
look at the GRC trilogy this trilogy is
a structured approach adopted by
organizations to align IT objectives
with business objectives first up we
have governance such a program has
motives like ensuring goals are achieved
providing strategic plans and so on
governance is taken care of by the
senior professionals of an organization
next up we have risk management here the
organization looks into mitigating all
types of risks such as investment
physical and cyber risks finally we have
compliance as discussed previously
compliance refers to abiding by the
defined laws and regulations so who do
y'all think develops a security policy
which is used to achieve the
organization's goals well it is done by
the senior management of an organization
let's have a look at the characteristics
of these security policies
first and foremost these policies should
support the wishin and mission of the
company all the business units should be
integrated in these security policies
they should also be
regularly updated and finally it is
important that these security policies
should be easy to understand so that
everyone can abide by them without any
problem in addition to security policies
a risk analysis team is also formed in
organization to perform the analysis of
each known risk there are various steps
to perform risk analysis let's have a
look at each of these first the team
makes an assessment of the value of the
company's assets then there is an
analysis made based on the risks to
assets and finally the team discovers
solutions to mitigate these risks now
that was all about the first domain of
CSP security and risk management let's
have a look at the second domain asset
security asset security deals with the
collection and protection of assets such
as data and devices here we will be
looking into data classification data
management data remanence and data loss
prevention so in data classification the
data owner classifies data a data owner
can be an individual or a group of
people who created the information and
are directly responsible for it this
classification is done based on a set of
predefined criterias at the end the
classification is annually reviewed to
see if there has to be some change
incorporated data management involves
managing the information lifecycle needs
of an enterprise in an effective manner
it also ensures that the data complies
to the set standards and finally data
management also ensures data validity
and integrity
moving on to data remanence it is a term
used for the residual of digital data
that is present even after trying to
erase the data data remanence should be
avoided as data should be completely
destroyed to tackle data remanence we
have methods like overwriting and
destruction to name a few in overwriting
other information is written over the
data several times so that the original
data can not be recovered in destruction
data and the storage device is
physically damaged to make recovery
difficult Asset security also looks into
data loss prevention here several
measures and risk assessments are
performed to ensure that information is
only available to authorized users let's
now move on to a third domain security
engineering as the name suggests this
domain talks about security architecture
security models cryptography
and physical security security
architecture establishes a common
practice for creating analyzing and
using architecture description within a
particular domain security architecture
takes the help of TCB that is trusted
computing base security parameter and
reference models to implement security
cryptography is also a part of security
engineering in cryptography information
is secured by converting data from a
readable format to a non readable format
and vice-versa
moving to a fourth domain we have
communications and network security this
domain is all about network structures
transmission methods and security
measures used to achieve CI a in an
organization OSI model is the foundation
of networking this model that is the
open systems interconnection model OSI
model describes how data is transferred
from one computer to another the OSI
model consists of seven years starting
from physical layer then data link layer
Network layer transport layer session
layer presentation layer and finally
application layer in the first layer
that is physical layer transmits raw bit
stream over the physical medium then
data link layer defines the format of
data on the network network layer
provides logical addressing and it also
provides path determination using local
addressing the fourth layer that is
transport layer provides end-to-end
connections in this layer data is
transmitted using transmission protocols
including TCP and UDP the session layer
maintains connections and it is also
responsible for controlling ports and
sessions the sixth layer that is a
presentation layer ensures that data is
in a usable format and finally in the
seventh layer that is the in the
application layer human-computer
interaction happens here applications
can access the network services the
communications and network security
domain also talks about firewalls we can
define a firewall as a hardware or
software which is used to block the
incoming or outgoing traffic from the
Internet to your computer then we also
have the ideas ideas has known as the
intrusion detection system this is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system IDs is used together with
the firewall and a router
move into identity and access management
a fifth domain
have a look at what this domain is all
about this domain of CISSP is all about
the access control identification
authorization and attacks on access
control and its countermeasures to be
able to access a data set or a resource
a subject has to be identified
authenticated and authorized identity
management Kerberos and access criteria
are few of the crucial fields here in
Identity Management through automated
means users are identified and
authenticated this domain also speaks of
Kerberos and authentication protocol
that is based on symmetric key
cryptography and provides end-to-end
security access to data shouldn't be
granted to anyone and everyone in fact
it should be granted based on the level
of trust and the job role in the
organization it is also better if it is
provided based on the location and the
time let's now have a look at our sixth
domain security assessment and testing
so in this domain we will look into
audits security control assessment and
testing reports as you might have heard
of the term audit it is nothing but a
repeated process wherein an independent
professional evaluates and analyzes
evidence then we have one durability
assessment where in IT risks are
identified and evaluated it helps in
identifying quantifying and prioritizing
vulnerabilities a well-planned and
executed assessment and test rata G can
provide valuable information about risk
and risk mitigation the assessment and
test is executed by a working group
called the integrated product team
testing is performed to check the data
flow between the application and the
system up next we have the security
operations domain the seventh domain of
CSP is all about investigations
monitoring and logging disaster recovery
and change management here we will look
into the fields of digital foreign six
incident management and parameter
security investigation of a computer
crime is also known as computer foreign
six in digital foreign six data is
examined to identify recover and analyze
opinions about digital information
incident management works to restore the
services to normal as soon as possible a
team called the incident response team
is deployed to handle such emergencies
incidence response is defined as a
practice of detecting a problem
determining its cause
minimizing the damage resolving the
problem and documenting each step this
team provides management with sufficient
information and defense the company
against future attacks in parameter
security there is parameter defense
which allows us to detect and keep a
check on unauthorized physical access
this field also controls the access to
the facility moving on to a eighth and
final domain we have software
development security as the name
suggests this domain talks about
security in a software development
lifecycle here we will be looking into
topics like API malware spyware adware
social engineering attacks and SQL
injection attack let's start off with
the application program interface known
as API API is basically a collection of
protocols and functions used to create
applications
it supports formats such as
representational state transfer rest and
simple object access protocol rest is
nothing but using the present features
of the web in a simple way and soap
which is an acronym for simple object
access protocol is a messaging protocol
for exchanging data among computers now
let's move on to malware as a security
threat malware is a term which refers to
malicious software viruses ransomware
and worms we can also call Trojan virus
as a form of malware which is capable of
disguising itself as a legitimate
software malware is basically a broad
term that refers to a variety of
malicious programs one way to protect
your software from malware is to always
double check your downloads moving on to
a next security threat spyware as the
name suggests this is a software that
typically spies on your system spyware
is also a type of malware which is used
to secretly gather information of the
Wiggum to give it to a third party those
programs that secretly record all that
you do on your computer are called
spyware it is always advise to turn on
popup blockers to prevent spyware next
up we have adware adware is also known
as advertising supported software it is
a type of malware that constantly
displays ads and pop-ups some of such
ads can also gather your information at
times adware is not all that dangerous
but it is a hassle as it is a gateway to
unwanted advertising on the screen and
it can also change the browser homepage
ad version
known to display unwanted annoying
advertisements on your screens let's now
have a look at social engineering
attacks it is basically the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving their confidential information
this attack lers victims into handing
over their confidential data this attack
takes place by tricking the human mind
the most common social engineering
attacks are fishing spear fishing and
bailing fishing attack fishing attack is
a practice wherein the hacker usually
sends fraudulent emails which appear to
be coming from a very trusted source
this is done to install malware or to
steal sensitive data like credit card
information and various other login
credentials spear phishing attack is a
variation of phishing here the attacker
targets a specific individual or a group
of people and in wailing phishing attack
well the powerful and prominent
individuals are may targets moving on to
a next attack we have SQL injection
attack SQL injection attack is a type of
code injection attack in a database
driven website the hacker manipulates a
standard SQL query it allows attackers
to tamper with the existing data here
malicious code is inserted into the SQL
Server to obtain information those were
the eight domains of CSP I hope you guys
found this informative and I hope you
enjoyed watching it if you have any
doubts please leave them in the comment
section below and we will be happy to
assist you thank you for watching stay
tuned and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here